توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت  ...
توت توت  أحلى الرحلات
توت توت  وقت العطلات
توت توت  أحمل أصحابي
توت توت من باب البيت
توت توت توت توت توت توت توت  ...
توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت  ...
سأوصل سلمى إلى جدتها ***  ستقضى العطلة  في صحبتها
لتصنع كعكا توت توت  ***   ولتخبز خبزا توت توت
بكل الحب وطيب القلب  ***   وتحضر أطعم بسكويت
توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت  ...
وأحمل للمنتزه العامل  ***  سيعمل فيه ليوم كامل
يقم الشارع توت توت  ***   كي يصبح رائع توت توت
ليصير نقيا حلوا وبهيا ***   لتسعد فيه مهما بقيت
توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت  ...
ومعنا في القاطرة مهرج  ***  بمرح صوب العمل سيخرج
ليسعد طفلا توت توت  ***  وليرسم بسمة توت توت
بأنف أحمر ..وشعر أخضر ***   يرقص ويغني توت توت ....
توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت توت  ...